Không, đây thì không phải tâm thiếu, nhưng mà nó cũng thấy gọi là nó là chúng tôi đồng hành với tâm thiếu.
Đây là số ra, hay là số, là tí để mua lưng thực của thời gian màu cấp.
Hãy xưa, hãy số này nó không khá lĩnh sổ hậu.
Trong rồi nó có kia khai về tưởng ra mình, có bao nhiêu người này.
Mỗi người sẽ có được một số trà, nó có cất gạo, nó lưng thực để càn theo.
Hãy gà ngày xưa mình có thể mà mình không có số này là mình không mua được.
Lột gạo luôn.
Ờ, rất là phần chẳng.
Sao, người ta hay một câu lập của mình như một số ra.
Đúng, đúng, đúng, đúng, đúng, đúng, đúng, đúng, đúng, đúng.
Thời bao cấp là gì phải anh chiếc.
Em ngay của mạnh đặc quan của mùi nhật.
Vậy vào có vị, nó ra gọi người nó một chiếc lâu.
Mình nó một chiếc thà một số.
Nha nước, được đẩy nhà, rất của người dư rất là một chú này.
Bọn nào, mình vài, dù ăn, sạm vào một tất cả một chiếc điều phải qua nước thiếu.
Ờ, cái như không có đêm.
Lâu được.
Cảy cảm ơn có tiệt.
Ờ, mẹ, số một đánh mình một số để giấc chiếc.
Vậy giờ, cái gì thì nó lịch áp tặc lồ ăn người gặp đúng.
Chả sử.
Mũ mẹ em, gình mỗi tháng chỉ, được mô vài cân gạo vôi.
Thế là phải ăn đổ vô vài.
Trần lột.
Này sử vô mẹ được tôi, nhưng...
Bất kẻ ra mà phải ăn nhà, đúng, gó, nó mời người có.
Thì ăn toàn phải cơm chụn với gạo hoài, vì cái sánh đủ.
Gạm gì được ăn cơm không, mình rất, bây giờ mình bỏ cơm không.
Chần con chán, nhưng người còn còn bỏ cơm luôn.
Bởi bảo gắng chỗ mình nghĩ, thì đang trực mấy rất là dương vị trị bận của thời gian này.
Sổn and feel này, chiếc ca, dô, chiếc bệm dâu, chiếc xe đặc phượng quanh.
Mỗi thú để vô có một câu chuyện dân của mưa định.
Đúng không, mình ăn tự nước là cây, sẽ đặc phượng quanh.
Sửa cái xe đặc phượng quanh, nó quyết.
Lạm là đặc phượng, cứu đặc phượng, mấy xe đặc phượng, nó không có khách lý tạm.
Một quanh, nó khách lý tạm, nó khách lý tạm.
Đó, nó sẽ sống thế nào, phổ, nó không, phổ.
Hòa thân như bác chất mình thấy mình là đất là dâm sâu.
Hằng sau khi chế nhau, tùi vũa ra uống,
cái ngh Neil and trẻ con thì chơi ngoài đưa hịt, tối về nho hỏa của định doàn.
Hóa, hóa nhau.
Bảo ta, h》 có nhiều đô, thấy bảo tốc tông.
Em muốn cho vô mẹ đi xem.
Ờ.
Hóa, hòa nheu.
Cũng vầy hà lỏi bị gý thang failed, giúp rất nhiều định và nó thành thẩy này.
Tìm chí ổ ở đâu dính xin khuò lịt anh vừa người sống
Vậy thì hãy hỏi cái này
Vậy như của mẹ tạm có kể cho bạn về chuyện người mọc đó
Và follow me ngay, để xem xưa đi tiếp theo của bạn tạm hà nội nhá
Bye bye